a big welcome to the stars of the new
Netflix action comedy The Outlaws
welcome to the studio folks here's an
exclusive First Look by the way at the
movies poster I'm seeing it for the
first time as well actors and real-life
friends Adam DeVine and Nina Dobrev are
reuniting in this film Devine plays a
bank manager named Owen who's engaged to
Parker played by Dobrev with just days
until his wedding Owens bank is robbed
by the notorious ghost Bandits who he
actually comes to believe are his future
in-laws played by Ellen Barkin and
Pierce Brosnan love of the setup here's
a preview
Mr and Mrs McDermott it is an honor to
come here come here
[Music]
let's forget the formality Shelby Mr
McDermott all that crap yeah call me
Billy oh well you must be Parker's dad
because YouTube is exactly the same
hey Lily yep thanks okay Mom
that's weird because I never forget to
lock the front door to call me my wife a
liar huh
you calling my wife a liar is that ever
you're accusing her you want me to get
your face off
here's broth and finding another level
there
I've join us now first on CBS mornings
uh good morning to both of you good
morning we all love laugh out loud it is
hilarious yes it is a good old-fashioned
Laugh Out Loud Comedy and I I love that
I I appreciate it so much Adam you are
known for these comedic roles but in
this you play a bank manager described
as straight laced I keep it very
dramatic uh in this role you as you can
tell by that trailer
no I I it's uh yeah there's a place
someone that's that uptight you know
yeah because I'm not that I'm a great
I'm not that in real life you know I'm
just a great actor and I can pull it off
did you pull anything from your own
in-law relationship uh for this movie oh
my in-law is
actually a bank robber so oh okay I'll
Ritz that from her that works perfectly
yeah is he always this funny on set Nina
is this is this what you dealt with
while you were working yeah Adam the
whole cast but obviously Adam in
particular yeah yeah let's all talk
about it but I've heard you say this
movie was the most fun that it really
didn't feel like didn't feel like acting
because Adam told me backstage or in the
Green Room that there were no hidden
messages here we just really wanted
everybody to have fun I say mission
accomplished on that I agree we we had a
blast making this movie and I think
audiences are gonna have an absolute
blast watching was there a lot of improv
that's what I was wondering yeah of
course yeah yeah a lot you know I think
I just keep hearing like movie
Executives say like why do we need to
make this film now and I'm like because
it's funny man that's what it's about
we're just trying to make people laugh
like you're not gonna be at the end of
this film and be like was this about
global warming like hidden agenda
morality you've had in this movie for a
long time
yeah yeah so this came to me these
writers benzov and Evan Turner they
pitched me this idea like probably like
six or seven years ago oh wow and then I
wrote it in what was the idea uh just
like your in-laws or Outlaws and they
rob your bank okay and I was like that's
a really funny idea and then I lost that
notebook for like
like five or six years and then I
finally dug it out and uh called them up
and was like this is a great idea for a
movie what have you done with it and
they were like nothing we thought you
hated it and luckily uh they didn't do
anything with it and we were able to do
it so by looking at you I can tell that
you're uh Supreme athlete thank you for
saying that my God no problem you got
the talking points yeah I did I did um
but you do some stunts and and Pierce
Brosnan is also James Bond yeah did he
give you any pointers you could pull it
all off well there there's difference
with our stunts oh he looks cool doing
it right I look like uh like I injured
myself because I probably did my
favorite part in the trailer is when
you're going up the stairs into the bank
and your gun follows out of you yeah
that's a pretty good moment it was good
he's like the anti-robber but the two of
you have worked together before there's
a rapport between talk about that Nina
yeah two of you all we shot a movie ten
years ago yeah like probably 10 years
ago yeah years ago and then Adam
photobombed me on a red carpet at the
Teen Choice Award yeah why did you do
that now was that funny at the time yeah
I'm really funny now uh both but but I
think at the time I was just like who's
this creepy weird dude behind yeah why
did she's kind of stalk her uh of the
Teen Choice Awards were like
fun out there like photo bomb people and
I'm like I just hate me but
whatever and so I'm like behind Nina
and she's like oh like who she doesn't
know who I am like some creep but uh
that's just right it's the thing about
your face too you have very very no no I
mean your facial expressions
I'm trying to say
[Laughter]
that are very funny without you saying
anything that's what that's the point I
was trying to make so poorly here
squishy very punchable face but do you
do that on purpose is what I'm saying
you clearly there's something that you
do these are just genetic scale I I
can't help it I wish it were a little
different to tell you the truth but uh
because you guys have such great
chemistry on screen and here in our
studio we want to play a little version
of The Newlywed Game with you so I have
a couple of paddles here okay once I
said uh says Adam the other side says
Nina yeah all right we did that right uh
and here we go it's gonna be uh pretty
rapid fire so let me know when you're
ready are you ready okay game show voice
Tony game show voice I know you better
do this you got it you've done actual
games I'm psyched out no I don't know
all right let's do this here we go all
right live anything first question who's
the better partner and crime
the better partner in crime like okay
yeah oh so you got to send each other
okay teamwork all right yeah who's more
likely to be favored by their in-laws
who's more likely to embarrass their
significant other
that makes perfect sense that makes
perfect sense okay um who's more likely
to be late to set
we're both pretty good we're both pretty
punctual okay keep the paddles down yeah
who's more likely to forget their lines
oh yeah
oh oh you're saying you ooh okay I just
will say other things okay okay it won't
be the line but it'll be some other
stuff last one and this is the most
important one who has the better dance
moves at a party Nina
pelvis there in the opening scenes yeah
I don't want to show off it's too early
in the morning I'm not fully stretched
but yeah Adam you got hit by a cement
truck when you were 11. sounds like a
joke it's not but it's not it's not a
joke not a metaphor you couldn't walk
for two years that's right yes so I'm
just I would have never picked you as a
great dancer no offense but I would how
did that change your life other than the
obvious uh while I walk with a limp uh
well people say people say I have like a
funny walk and and when I run I've I've
had in the past people will be like like
for while we're shooting I like have her
chasing and I'm running they're like oh
my God your run is so funny like even
you even run funny and you're like this
is that's crazy and I'm like I was doing
the best I could
all right well you guys Crush hit in
this movie yeah you do Adam DeVine and
Nina Dobrev thank you very much
appreciate it thank you
The Outlaws can be streamed on Netflix
on July 7th July 7th is a long way off
no go see it though